retour dans le focus du jour à carquive
dans le nord-est de l'Ukraine en mars
dernier leur porteur c'était rendu dans
le quartier bombardé de salfica une zone
résidentielle frappée jour et nuit un
quartier fantôme ou seul une poignée
d'habitants avaient pris la décision de
rester terrifié isolée mais plein de
courage leur histoire avait profondément
ému nombre de nos téléspectateurs qui
nous avaient demandé de leur nouvelle
nos équipes sont donc retourner sur
place les rencontrer cet reportage de
Mélina Huet et Catherine Laurent strent
[Musique]
salle tipka banlieue nord de rarkif en
mars dernier
un quartier devenu fantôme bombardé par
les Russes nuitées jour
chez les quelques âmes restées malgré
tout Ludmila 75 ans jamais loin du
sous-sol transformé en abri anti-aérien
[Musique]
toujours debout et furieux vivant au
milieu des ruines
nous sommes retournés à Celtica où les
bonbons cessé de pleuvoir
en septembre les troupes russes ont été
repoussés de la région de harkis
nous retrouvons Ludmila et Sanya grand
sourire sur leur visage émus après des
mois de souffrance
dans sa maison
la cave de son immeuble en réalité où
elle vit toujours
durablement affecté elle ne se sent
toujours pas capable de remonter dans
son appartement malgré le froid qui
s'installe à nouveau
jumeaux
de fortune tenant sur des piles de
provision qu'elle a amassées pour tenter
de survivre
des réserves en majorité distribuées par
les habitants et les autorités locales
dans les mois qui ont suivi notre
première rencontre
Ludmila a rempli son bunker elle a aussi
reçu des nouvelles réconfortantes de sa
famille son premier petit enfant est né
au cœur de la guerre mais hors de danger
des nouvelles qui lui ont donné la force
de continuer
[Musique]
avec l'eau de Mila Sanya était l'un des
5 résidences restés dans ce bloc
d'immeubles
mais aujourd'hui
il jubile
[Musique]
les ascenseurs sont depuis repartis et
l'électricité et le gaz ont fait leur
réapparition de manière sporadique
a passé des mois à réparer son
appartement après plusieurs tirs de
Rocket grade
[Musique]
dans les bombardements Sany avait perdu
son chat compagnon fidèle au milieu du
chaos
lorsque nous l'avions rencontré
il était dévasté
[Musique]
des mois plus tard il s'est trouvé un
nouveau complice
les survivants de saltifka dépendent
essentiellement de l'aide à portée par
les ONG et les autorités locales
il profite pour le moment du calme de
leur quartier
chaud
un souhait d'harmonie et de paix alors
même que la guerre qui a bouleversé leur
vie continue de faire rage sans que l'on
puisse en voir la fin
[Musique]
la suite de sparadirect est les sports
tout de suite les journals des sports
avec forcément du foot l'entrée en lice
ce soir des Bleus pour leur premier
match de la Coupe du monde